[Music]
what is essary
well essary has become a lot of things
over the past 15 years but when we
started in 2004 it was a pretty simple
concept it's what you get when you treat
operations as a software problem and you
staff it with software engineers and
everything else came from that
[Music]
essary is a way of thinking and
approaching production it's a set of
principles and practices and so in a
sense most people who are engineers who
could be developing a system can also be
an SRE working on that same system and
when we talk to somebody about joining
s3 we're really looking for a few things
first of all did they have a natural
tendency to avoid toil a lot to automate
it away make a computer do it right if
they're allergic to doing things by hand
over and over again and if they have the
computer skills to take the work that
they've been doing by hand and make a
computer do it instead they've got a
good character trait for essary secondly
can they have a complexity right and in
particular can they take a complex and
maybe not well-defined problem and come
up with a scalable technically
reasonable solution for it and implement
that solution we call those skills
non-abstract a large systems design and
it's a skill that pretty much every s3
uses every single day finally we look
for an innate curiosity about how things
work right we're looking for people who
will learn over the course of their
lifetime in essary and understand
systems as they development as they
change when we find someone with those
attributes we have someone with the
potential to be a really excellent
essary
so once we find someone who generally
fits that shape that's when the real
work begins
when it comes to SRE there's a lot to
learn from reliability best practices
and design patterns to the ins and outs
of complex production systems to
incident management best practices and
more over the years we've developed
hundreds of hours and thousands of pages
of material to help develop those
inclinations into excellent production
skills once someone gets up to speed on
an SRE team at Google then we spend a
lot of effort on continuing education
things like rotations and short-term
projects great azari's aren't hired
they're actually trained and their
skills are honed over time
[Music]
Google was a lot smaller than it is
today when we started essary
in the beginning history was just a few
people in a couple offices today we're
more than 2500 folks spread around the
world basic SEO principles scale from
very small to super large as long as you
keep them in mind then with them guide
you along the way you will end up in the
right place if I were starting another
company from scratch again I would
definitely be doing SRA from day one
[Music]
for a long time we wouldn't talk about
sre outside of Google it was the secret
sauce but a few years ago we started to
rethink that now we spend a lot of time
working to build a large and vibrant sre
community we've published several books
and also dozens of articles videos and
trainings with much more to come almost
all of this material is available for
free on Google s eries homepage we know
that an important part of s eries value
is creating something meaningful and
lasting for a larger community well
that's the uncomfortably exciting part I
have a lot of ideas but the truth is I
don't really know for certain now that
this area is grown to be a global
community and not just a Google thing
the future of the profession is
determined by the progress and
innovations of everyone in essary right
and if you'd asked me in 2004 what would
become of the SRE team I would not have
predicted this right I thought it was
going to be a very small niche part of
computer science so what I did predict
is that the community of smart and
motivated people who now make up the
global essary teams will continue to
come up with new ideas they'll continue
to innovate they'll continue to advance
the state of the art and advance what is
possible and I'll be part of that but
just part of it so really I'm looking
forward to seeing what you all create
[Music]
you